could this be the first new war of 2023  the country of Pakistan is on the verge  of Civil War an extremist group called  The TTP has taken control of the  Northern Territories and they even set  up their own parallel government in  defiance of the official one it's a lot  like what happened in 1971 when the  country last broke into Civil War  splitting the nation into modern  Pakistan and Bangladesh except this time  it's looking like Pakistan could split  not into two separate pieces but four on  top of this Pakistan's economy is  collapsing right now people everywhere  are running out of gas and the entire  country could Collapse by the end of the  year people have gotten so desperate  that they're selling gas illegally in  giant plastic balloons just to cook  meals there isn't even enough oil to  keep their trains running Pakistan is  being pushed to the edge which is why  you should subscribe for our full video  on this soon